Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to party Hard tycoon now if you remember party hard
It was a game about trying to murder everybody in a party so now there's a tycoon version of the game
I have no idea what that means, but I'm gonna give it a go oh hi. Oh
You can fast forward the calendar of the days long
Sure, you can only throw one party per calander day
There are five different grades. I'm gonna go to squat ah
Then you preview
Sure choose a theme. Well EAT ME of course it's gonna be a food fest for charity oh
Lovely. my person now?
Alright. I got ninja Brian over here and count Dracula. sure
Entrance fee well, it's charity. So we got to get something do not forget to check the grade to the party when managing a mark
huh?
your visitors... wha?
How does that work more it costs more means more visitors?
sure let's start the party then hi. Hello.
I don't know what's happening ah yes, let's get the Tunes
Bouncing over here, but that's the broken-down cars. Yes, sure I like this
Oh, yeah, let's get them bouncing over in ??? dream
Maybe over here right by the tuv you
Get it right there. Oh yeah, so people can dance on that lovely picnic blanket. I think
sure lighting projector
I don't know what the bar means, but sure
Yes
Smoke Cannon love it. Get those smoke cannons a blowin
sure start this party
I have no id-
Hi
Hello, hi Ninja Brian you're looking lovely today. Go count Dracula go oh, hi
There is no free table. What does free tables mean?
What do I what?
Dude, you didn't give me a tutorial or nothing. Oh boy. I'm not people aren't happy
I don't know what a free table is do not forget to engage your personnel. They boost your party, okay?
How do I do that things seem to be cut off on the bottom hang on wait?
Hang on everybody stop everybody stop everybody stop everybody get out get the fuck out get out
get the fuck out, okay,
I have no idea what the fuck happened.
I made some profit apparently. It's not profit if my investment was forty five hundred
My income was 126. I didn't exactly make a lot of money all right
We're gonna do this again and this time I'm actually going to think about what I'm doing, and I'm gonna read
We're gonna go cocktail knights now. Give me a beer now cocktails
Because it's slightly innuendos and I like it being a little innuendos. oh tables, okay?
We're gonna get we're gonna make it cheaper
Four dollars. Four dollars seems fine
And it should be free
Entrance fee is free. Yeah, that's it's free. It's gonna be free
That's what's gonna be great about this oh
ah
Tables.
I see
Okay, I think I'm starting to understand what this is all about
Oh, yeah, you guys are gonna be blasted with the music here. Oh, you are going to love it
Oh, yeah, let's get some old let's get a barbecue going oh hell. Yeah over in the bed area
Everyone loves having a barbecue in the bed area. Uh let's get a large table over here. Oh fuck yeah, brah
Decor ah
Let's focus on getting more music up in this and hairy up you can't do that not enough power one speaker for this table
Yeah, I think we're gonna like that. Oh, I think we're gonna like that alright. Let's go for it now the party can start
Let's go do it
Let's do it
Let's do it oh hi. Hello. Don't worry about it. It's free get in there party your hats off. Hey
Go on in have a good time. Hey you have a good time in there alright cool
You guys having fun great you guys go ahead. Oh yeah ninja Brian. Oh, you get it. Okay. Everyone's unhappy
Why why are you unhappy? I don't know what he's doing there we go
Jeezum why do I even have you around here? If you're not gonna do anything?
Light oh, oh it is lit. Oh it is lit. Is there no one here?
wait
Why are you unhappy?
It's cocktails night start a show right here get it on Ninja Brian get it on oh
Oh, hell, yeah, oh
uh
Count Dracula get get the fuck out of the way serve food
everywhere ah
That's what we needed all right. We got macho man, randy savage as the only guest at this party
We have done fucked up somewhere
we have fucked up yep,
I invited two people
Feel like it lost a lot of money there lost a lot of money on that one
But you know early start here early start ooh my house. Well that's better. Oh, let's just do that. Oh
Let's get a beer fest going on lots of food and fights. Hell. Yeah
Love it alright. We're Gonna
I need to make some money so let's fucking do this with a lot of entrance fee alright
Everybody hold on to your dicks spear barrel. We're gonna need a beer barrel. That's like a must we're gonna have one
There, we're Gonna have one
There we're going to have one in that room there going to be one in that room
There's going to be a barbeque over in that room. There's going to be a
small table Spitter Spatter table labels here, they're
Everywhere no one's going to be at a loss for
Table space still not 100% sure about this, but you know what we're gonna. Go for it all right now. I'm feeling it
Yeah, let's get some music in here some Tunes
Hell, yeah, okay all right here some decor ornamental cactus
Oh, that is big something for people to get impaled on if they make mistakes. Yeah, that's good. Okay now
We've got something going on here
So let's start the party
Let's get people in here. Let's just start. I want I want. I want it
I want everything get everything everything everywhere do the things get the food
Do the food get it
Get it going you serve food here
Somewhere serve food where I don't know what you're doing. Why are you guys?
start a show
Okay, I don't know what's happening. I do not know what's happening. I think it's working I
Think this party is working. I think everyone is super happy
Yeah
Okay, I don't know yeah, okay. He did something there he did something
I don't know why he did, but he did something so far so goo. Why are they all out there?
Why are you all out on the street? What are you doing over there boobs McKenzie? What do you doing out there?
You cosplayers get in the party and get it partying up
I'm so cool. You guys don't understand how cool. I am if you just understand how cool
I am it's just getting my house and party with me have a great time
Why aren't you guys partying with me? Bye?
Did you did you have fun?
Did you enjoy? Your-
HOLY SHIT
I think I did good! people were disappointed, but oh well
Too hungry 14 expected more hype and fun than whatever, huh spend all the money they had
Invited all the people who was invited to your party based on entrance fees and people who are passing by and I made a little
Bit of profit, so I'm gonna consider that a success
Yes, I did it. I did it. I did it up. I did it up. Oh
I like this guy he reminds me of medicine and therefore myself, so I'm gonna go to this guy. Oh, hell. Yeah
We're gonna get the real carnival the carnivale. I'll give you something cool, but
Funk oh punk rock. Oh, I got to go Carnival
Oh, we're gonna be so glamorous alright. Everything seems to be locked so let's fast forward to the next challenger day. Oh
They're alright, okay. We got some fans over there. We got a lot of equipment
So what we need to do is we need to make this a lot more. Hype. Oh
Way more hype so what we're going to do is we're going to make this carnival dance and have fun
Love is in the air. Oh indeed
It is and ohni dididi do and I'm gonna get him to pay a lot of money
I know, they're gonna expect hype, but I'm about to bring the hype. Are you ready for the hype from?
Lighting projectors, so I got it like establish one room as the dance room right so one rooms got to be the dance room
So let me hang on so if I ok let's sell some of these beer things and let's assume that this needs to be more
Centralized as in over there, so we're going to get rid of the decorative cactus
I hate to do that, but you got to do what you got to do all right purple rug. Oh
I hope it's shag oh my god and people are gonna cut this rug so hard oh
That's good. That's good. Oh yeah, oh
No, that's wrong. Okay, alright. I think this is Gonna be something
I don't know if it's gonna be good, but it's gonna be something so let's get this party started
Oh, let's serve some drinks up in here. Yes serve some food get some food go in there
Oh, yeah, get the drinks. Where's the drinks get the drinks. Where's the goddamn drinks get the drinks at going?
Yeah, it's the drinks. Go the drinks
Get those drinks in there and go yeah
Yeah Yeah
Yeah
Get the party started dance dance dance dance dance start a show little guy go over there and dance
Start a show start a show you start a show over here now boom boom boom boom boom boom boom serve food serve food serve food
Serve food yes, yes yes every. Oh look at him go
Oh fuck yeah, oh
Hell yeah, oh hell
Yeah, sir food. I think I don't know what you're doing
I don't even know if you're valuable in any capacity, but you know it's a good enough for me. Hell. Yeah. Hell yeah
All of you losers being outside like a bunch of losers are just losers and I hate you
You don't deserve to be as party people as me yeah, let's start another show hell
Yeah, go. Go he'll get out look at him go oh yeah. Hell yeah! *Mark making his mating noices*
Start another show. Oh fuck yeah over here. How about that?
*Mark making some more of his mating noices*
I don't know what's happening it. I think my noises are helping I
Think I have no idea, okay, all right. You know I think I think oh, I think we did it
I think that was a good party. I think it was good party good guy. I think that was a good party
I'm not gonna Lie feel good about that one. Oh
Yeah, we lost fans, but that's okay. Hell. Yeah ah
We're starting on we're doing okay? All right, okay? I'm gonna try one more whoa
Tiny Club, Ooh
I want an actual club
TO DANCE PARTY (i think that what he said)
Back in black calls visitors to the show give some likes and add 75% more hype? oh
Hello, of course. I want that. Okay. I'm gonna go to the tiny club hang on. I'm Gonna go over here
I want to I sell my shit yeah, I don't know if it is actually gonna help
But I'm just trying to concentrate things down. I don't know if it's gonna help at all
it probably won't
But you know what I can't know until you experiment. Okay, you start a show
Right here baby what is this oh, hell. Yeah, oh hell yeah!
oh get the party going
There we go. That's what I'm talking about all right?
All right, all right all right, okay?
So these things the trade things are the things that people spend money on
And that's the only way that you can get money out of people
otherwise they're just kind of done partying and it only gets hype because of the
Accessories that you have so I get it now, okay?
I'm understanding it. I got a little bit of understanding going on it. Oh yeah
Oh, yeah, you guys are in for the little show. Oh yeah, oh
Yes
so hype
So hype! look how happy they were oh my God we had 18 people thrilled
WE THRILLED 18 PEOPLE?!?!
We got fans. It worked it concentrated it worked
It worked I want to throw in there, but I just don't have the money for it
But I could just concentrate it down. You know what let's try to do that
No, I couldn't afford anything if I do that all right I've got equipment here
Let me go here again, and then sell stuff and get that going hopefully that'll be good lots of food and fights
No, please okay. Let's make this a lot more efficient now. All right everything is very centralized and also
I'm completely out of money. Did I mention that I've not been smart with my money here?
That's okay because this party is going to get started and it is going to be off the hook
Oh get that food in there. Yeah get ready for the show, baby
Oh, yeah, keep the show started baby get it going on now
Oh yeah, baby. Dance the night away now. Oh yeah, baby start the show right now now
Oh yeah, baby
Everybody's mother each other. Oh yeah, baby. Get the hype going now. Oh yeah, baby
My singing is really bad. Whoo yeah, baby. It's empty
I forgot about that one hang on go, but none of money, okay, never mind. I have it now. Oh people are unhappy
Why are they unhappy? I have no idea
Ye-yeah, something tells me this one isn't going as beautifully as the other one was
Mmm, okay, I think
We're people happy I
Don't know we're people happy this light show is awesome check my last video from Hashtag beer fest of funky. I like that
I can't I like that damn it. Oh
My people enjoyed it
Still made money, but I don't I didn't make any of my investments. Oh
Frizzen party, okay party Bikers cat I'll go a chat. I'm alma Lenny all kind of I think I know what's going on
I think I know what I'm doing wrong
I think I think my problem is the one like I'm learning a lot about the game already
Whatever that's fine what I need to do is I need to
lower the
Fee the entrance fee needs to be way lower, and I think that's important
Is that although?
Yeah, I'm not gonna. No entrance fee at all none to start this party straight up, okay, all right
So you saw me fail a whole bunch, and that's totally fine. I was learning but now that I know
Now that I'm kind of know what to do
I'm gonna start a new game because I spent way too much money where I was not supposed to spend money and
I need to get this party started because if I don't do this party, right?
Then I'm not going to do myself right and if there's one thing that markiplier does its I do myself right?
What the hell is this?
Try not to get kick ass at this race and love will find you whoo
people have some fun than get in a bad mood
uhh.. County?
Madness with food and fight sure let's go with that one
I have no idea oh God these assholes again alright, so the entrance fee is Gonna be
moderate I don't know why
Why is that? Why does that increase it? You know what whatever. I got money like that, so I'm gonna keep money like that
We're gonna get it banging in here and that is just what we're gonna do. hell Yeah, all right. I've got everything
for an
Amazing party, I've got speakers boxing every just blasting with sound I've got tables
I've got beer I've got everything I need to make this party as
Great as it possibly can be we've got so much hype. We've got so much
Booze it's Gonna be great. the only thing I don't want is this one here cuz that's just a waste
So what we need... here we go coloured palm. That's what we need that's what I was looking for right by the oh yeah
That's the kind of decorum that we need in here because we need to pump up the height, but we don't need-  ooh
heck
Heck ooh, I don't know how that works, but ok don't know how that works, but apparently those connected
I think that's all for the cheap stuff. Yeah, all that stuff is expensive
I can't afford that
But it is going to- it's going to be so lit
You know what, let's get another snow cannon in here cuz why not why the frick not there is no reason not
It is all yes. Oh yes. Oh that is good. Oh that is good. Okay? We are not leaving here
We have pumped out all the party that we can we've taken all the power. We've gotten all the decor
Let me put another stop sign over there. Just to make it nice and linked up
Oh, just stop do not cross that line you the party is over that way you don't need to go any farther
There's even other of a stop sign on the wall over there
You don't need to go any farther the party is already starting and you are late for it, so let's get this party started
Come on. Let's do this. Oh yeah, get it get it mmM
Fill those tables up get people drinking in their cups. Yeah, okay things see doodle. Doodle. Do I'll get it started
Get it started here they come oh, I think those people are topless great your oh
yeah!
pump it up, hmmm yeah. Do I have to turn them on?
I have to turn them on really. I didn't know I had to do that. Oh
Geez huh yeah huh? Yeah
Light it. Huh light it up. Yes this
Party is real good. Yeah, I like it
Uh-huh, okay cool let's do another round of shots yay
Put the party lights on where did they go, okay? All right?
I guess we're done with that now how hype was that
I was pretty good guys you all would go that party right you'd all go that party oh
Yeah, you would you know you would you know you would you know you would of course you would why wouldn't you?
WHY?!?! WHAT AM DOING WRONG?!?!
All right, so we the wave that is party hard tycoon. I'm not an expert at this game
I really am not uh it's kind of hard to figure out because I don't understand the mechanics hundred percent
But I was figuring it out, and it was kind of fun to be able to throw this party
So this game is not fully released yet. It is still just in like early access phase
I don't even know if it's on steam right now
But if it is I'll put a link in the description if there's a way for you guys to play it for yourself to put a link
In the description, it's pretty fun. I I
Gotta admit even though I'm a little confused and maybe I'm doing it wrong which wouldn't be surprised, but either way
Thank you so much for watching let me know how I did in the comments below and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye!
*Mark happily dancing*
The End